[Music]
all aboard
the moogan train hey happy tuesday
welcome around this trailer's
commentaries for the mugen train
you know it you love it um we're here to
talk about our behind the scenes
thoughts about the
uh episode you'll see some of our
deleted scenes we'll respond to comments
and questions from viewers like you then
tease you in next week's on his trailer
uh danielle and lon with me as always um
and as a special surprise we have a guy
who's actually seen the demon slayer
anime
from start to finish it's joestar
welcome back joe
oh just always happy to randomly slack
you and say
why haven't you done mugen train i know
and i was like
that's ridiculous and then uh about
three days later he's like
okay fine we'll do the moving train um
so here we are
all aboard the moog and train together
we've
never done we have done animes in the
past there's like a bunch of
honest animes that we made in the screen
junkies plus days that we
we farmed out but they seemed to know
what they were talking about um but this
was
the original gang taking taking a swing
at an anime and seeing what happened
this is not the very first one because
we just
and pokemon the first movie or the
whatever they could call that one for
whatever that's worth
um that counts yeah and this was uh for
me
fun i i liked going back into the world
of anime i mean my
i think all of our personal histories
are like we watched toonami and then
that was about
danielle you might have seen more than
than us now
uh i've seen a little bit but no it a
lot of it was very uh toonami based
so this one like i i've watched a couple
episodes of demon slayer just so that
this would make more sense to me it did
not
no i didn't i've seen a lot of like the
the standalone
great movie like i got into all those so
like i've seen like ghost of the shell
and akira and all the miyazaki's
like i got into that god bless you so
much yeah
joe's on our shared hulu account and i
always see a lot of uh
you're still in the mix man god bless
you yeah
still cranking through anime so give me
give us some context for
demon train demon slayer
steven flavor okay so the first thing
i'll say is
i was actually really surprised that it
is just straight up a long episode of
the show
uh because the two my hero academia
movies that have come out do a pretty
good job of being stand alone
like okay here let's catch you up here's
what's going on and
this isn't going to really be part of
the show with its own little like thing
um so i kind of thought this would be
that and no
it is literally like um when saturday
morning cartoons would just run the gi
joe movie like in four parts
um it's it's but uh so you got
you got demons okay and uh
you got this guy tandro he's a very good
boy
and then his family gets killed by
with her demonstr who just gets bit by a
demon
but she's holding the demon she's
something kind of new she's sort of a
weird
i mean she's a demon but she's still got
like her human brain so she lives in a
box on his back
until they can cure her how you live in
a box
that somebody else carries around like
you do this
it kind of reminded me of uh mr mr and
mrs freeze from batman where it's just
like he's just got her on ice until the
day he can like figure it all out like
he's just got to rob like 18 more big
diamonds and then
this is all set but they're traveling
the the countryside slaying demons
so he joins the he there's like an
actual like demon slayer like core like
it's an act there's an actual like
kind of green berets for demons uh in uh
in in this period in japan and he joins
up
uh forehead guy is a part of that and
um and scared guy is also a part of that
um
and uh your career moves very much long
story shorting this
um yeah very weird choice yes to go
into demon slaying but he's very he's
very horny for uh chandra's sister you
see
um so yeah
he's not just frightened also horny
two things something that i missed or
couldn't kind of tell from context is
like what's their relationship with all
the
i guess turn of the century dressed
people just kind of
hanging out on trains like are they
aware of the demons
war going on and they just accept it
they're like well demon on the train
again
guess i'm gonna be late it's definitely
not like a secret
war like the show hasn't go to my and
again i'm probably
i might be messing things up but i don't
think that like
i think people just know that it's it's
a thing but it's not like
in the world of the shadows there are
demons and no one knows and we have to
keep them safe like people are aware
that that it's a bet it's a that it's a
thing
because i'm not sure i've got to happen
in the street
yeah i'm not sure i fully grok that
though like i think i thought it was
more like
potter where it's like occasionally the
magic world may slip into the real world
but
people just like they don't they can't
see it you know like they don't notice
the the weird goings-on they just
assume it's something normal i think
that's what i thought
i'm sure i'm wrong but yeah no they're
not i don't think it's separate and
equal like harry potter
[Laughter]
pretty short what what i again i'm
derailing the whole thing but like
during the pilot i've seen that episode
of the show
he seemed surprised that demons it
wasn't like demons killed my family
jeez these demons what next he seemed
like to not know about demons i feel
like there's a time jump in there right
like demons kill his family years pass
now
yeah some like training years pass i
think it's more of like a um
this could happen to me okay my town
yeah all right
[Laughter]
and probably also a little bit of like
audience surrogate
i have to talk out loud a lot and ask
questions about demons okay
okay that that does make some sense all
right yeah i guess it was what was
throwing me was how little
people were reacting to um not the
demons but the demon slayers on the
train who are
really dressed to the nines but also
like when you're on a subway or train
back in the day like that's probably the
least weird thing you've seen is like a
guy in an orange kimono and a sword
they just show up and they're like
showtime like they couldn't be dancing
you know
normal and you're just like well there's
an anime thing at the convention center
it's not strange at all hi it's me the
guy on the red line that always plays
closing time on his acoustics
sir would you like to hear closing times
all right um we will have more questions
as they come up but uh let's dive right
into the honest trailer for
demon slayer kimitsu no yaiba mugen
train the movie
the honest trailer you learn japanese
just for this
trailer i did
[Music]
from uh japan comes what's probably not
the best
introduction to anime but if you're
already a fan
wipe that pocky dust off on your wall
scroll and get your hands on
demon slayer kimetsu the movie
joe what is the best introduction to
anime for a non-non-viewer
or a lapsed viewer i think i mean my
my like proper was probably the original
full metal alchemist
full metal alchemist brotherhood
probably a lot better
so i like i like that if you like you
say that like we're going to be like oh
i can't believe he said that
i don't know i'm very nervous very
talking about anime i will go with
whatever i say joe
yeah talking about anime online's
dangerous
if you like if you like avengers and and
the mcu probably might hear academia
okay i would jump in it's real good but
i like weird
i think what i liked about and not going
too much of a tangent about
uh this one is that it was so unlike
things that i watch
otherwise like i'm not looking for the
mcu with like a different
skin on it it's like uh i like that it
was kind of beholden to its own kind of
tone and tropes that didn't really exist
in western animation or
film it made me a little nostalgic for
dragon ball it's got that very dragon
ball like we're about to have a fight
but i'm gonna like talk for 20 minutes
at you
and we're going to have this whole like
back and forth about what kind of fight
we're
about to have and then we'll do the
fight like it's it's got that kind of
energy to it which i
it was like a would you like to have a
discussion about the meaning of violence
right yes yes it's very yeah it's very
like it's all
the structure is like all fight based
but it's not like you're always fighting
you're just like
all of your discussions are within the
context of like we're about to have a
fight but before we do
you should really know this about me i
mean i feel like that's largely
inescapable in anime at least for my
understanding but what i
what i liked was the the mix of tones
where it was like oh it's kind of a
horror thing or oh it got really dark
but no oh now it's goofy and silly like
it seemed to be able to jump and it does
the show does uh also like shift those
really well where you
you'll genuinely be like that's
upsetting and then horny coward will do
something funny
and then there will be like a really
cool uh action like there's an episode
in in the series where there's a
a demon in this like weird haunted house
and every time he hits this drum the
like planes of the house shift so like
the ceiling will become the floor and
everyone's just falling everywhere and
visually
i've never really it's very like a
samurai inception
and i've never really seen anything like
it before so yeah it it jumps those
tones really really well
yeah they're like on top of each other
there's there's a moment in this thing
where like a character has died and
they're very sad about it and then
there's like
a beat and then schtick like right like
the dead character is on screen still
and it's just like well we got it it's
time for some stick and it's like wow
that is just like colliding into each
other just moving
it's like we got to keep going you know
life goes on yeah uh all right
let's keep going aboard this mookin
train the mugen train
the dubbed virgin but don't worry we
watch it with subs too
promise check out the anime sensation
that everyone in their husbando bought a
ticket for
that not only saved the japanese box
office but had the biggest u.s opening
for a foreign film
ever and confused that of anyone who
wandered in to see what the fuss was
about
though
explain pig head man
uh what was that because each uh
character has this
whole sequence where they go into their
own fantasy world and like i could
pretty much get from context what their
dreams and desires were
uh without having seen the show uh pig
head man giving the girl the acorns i
was really
really lost by what is his what's his
driving modus operations
bit is that he's sort of bonkers so he's
like a weird vagrant that just lived in
the woods
uh that they kind of pick up along the
way um
and he's very you know obvi you get the
shtick from the movie but he he thinks
he's stronger and better than everybody
else but he's also just kind of like off
his rocker a little bit and wears his
forehead
he's actually i don't want to spoil the
show too much but there's like a bit
about what he actually looks like under
the bar head which is kind of funny and
unexpected but yeah he's just kind of
like off his rocker
okay all right just you're old he's a
manic pixie dream bore
the jerry obviously and george i think
we've got and then you need a kramer
the girl in the box is elaine
pretty
[Laughter]
okay we got 12 moons it's a whole
hierarchy
what's with all the breathing breath
stuff
in out okay uh keep going keep going
that's like making age of ultron your
first marvel movie
okay see thor's using his magic dream
jacuzzi to recover a vision of the
infinity stones
and you know what never mind just just
watch the punching
or skip it hop aboard the mugen train
a direct continuation of the demon
slayer series so it will not slow down
to explain who this veiny narrator is
why the hero keeps a small child gagged
in his backpack or why his friend looks
like the cover of a romance novel
written by pigs
i'm wearing the hide of the mountain god
on my head
oh he's just a guy wearing a severed
borehead that makes more sense
very slightly more sense we've been over
there but series fans will instantly
recognize this colorful cast of
characters
like zenitsu a pikachu you'll want to
slap instead of hug
you know who cares um you know doing a
little reading online just to make sure
i
had some context for the show people
hate that guy ooh no one likes zunitsu
uh i mean i guess i see why but i guess
he's much worse in the show
it gets old and he's like
it's weird it's weird like everyone else
is kind of everyone else is like kind of
arcing
you know very gradually like even
boyhead has feelings
sometimes now but yeah his shtick
remains like
i'm a coward and i'm horny and um
so he's like you said he's george
yeah he's just continued to be costanza
great yeah every time they check in if
he's slaved he was like well i got a lot
to do
[Laughter]
keep going in nosuke the series on
tsundere
which is the anime term for more than
one character trait oh
and tanjiro the saintly protagonist
literally a perfect human
great kid and you just know he makes
sure to smell nice too
his scent is overwhelming but i can
smell him just barely
there's a faint scent of demon on it too
the demon sin is getting stronger by the
moment
he smells the most like kibutsuji i
could smell that nesuko's hurt
and i can smell he has a strong sense of
justice
who don't even have a cool haircut so
you can safely ignore them
and team up with rengoku a samurai guy
fieri
who's become one with the flame broiler
and now runs the toughest dojo in flavor
town
he's ultra powerful pure-hearted and
loves to eat
fishy so if it helps your memory to just
call him goku i say roll with it
yeah um i thought this was cool that
like he's not
a character really from the show i mean
he's in it but they haven't given him
his due and they kind of built a great
myth and then chopped him down in his
prime just for uh just for the movie and
granted they're going off like a
blueprint laid down by
the manga right yeah yeah
so i guess this always was was bound to
happen but um
i think he's pretty much he he's the
best character i think
um and kind of crazy that if you watched
a uh
a show about these kids or the the main
three
it ends up being about this new
character who gets the whole finale to
himself
and like the biggest emotional moments
like you'd usually think that it would
be about
the main character but uh but good for
them because
i'm a fan um r.i.p rp goku
uh it's it's it you know that it works
really well as an introduction because
by the end
it is it if there is impact to losing
him at the end and how sad they are it
feels earned
even though we know that they only met
this character at the beginning of the
movie it's not like this is a guy from
the pilot that they've known a lot they
lit like the whole first act is who's
this guy you know like uh
so yeah it's it's it's his character in
particular i think is like
arcs really well it is like built up
very well so by that final battle
there are real stakes yeah yeah and they
cry real tears
birds cry in this movie that's how
intense things get
in that bird no it it's fun too because
in the show it's
you spend so much time um with tandro
and his sister
and uh and their friends and then when
they finally like reach this level where
they realize that like all the
stuff they've gone through like they've
barely scratched the surface and there's
this whole like top tier of demon
slayers of which guy fieri is one
and so like they've sort of seen that
guy on a pedestal
and like from a distance basically but
not really had any interaction with them
and then like the first time yeah they
get to connect with them like he gets he
gets uh he gets axed just is pretty cool
well there you go all right keep going
are there demons to slay aboard this
mugen train
i'm going to level with you there are
there are several
like and movies
to sleep with
hilarious by having sick frightened
children do all of his dirty work
nap time orphans then yeah pause i guess
there's just
is there less of a taboo against like
hitting children in japan because
they make a very heroic moment out of
rengoku choking a small child it's like
yeah sometimes you just gotta hit a kid
they're gonna die ladies selfish orphans
okay they wanted good dreams they want
good dreams for themselves they're very
self-focused
so i had a question about that were they
all dying because i took it to mean that
they were all
like dying and wanted one last good
dream
that gets aft he should not be
on a train like that's that is a
contagious disease folks
that is in the not not to spoil the
deleted scenes oh oh i
made it into delete yeah all right keep
that
mask at least mask up if you've got tv
then just when you think the movie
trainer has fully gone off the rails
middle management demon akuza shows up
with a burning desire
to bring goku i mean seduce ringoku
i mean fight ringoku yeah fight
that's what he wants to do i can tell
just by looking at you that you're
strong
we could spar with each other endlessly
what a magnificent attack
such skills movements what unbelievable
strength that iron glad
stance those reflexes brilliant you
haven't reached your
feet yes keep your eyes on me we'd be
able to fight each other for the rest of
eternity
yeah right so we may have added in the
bleep for comedic
the point is uh you know game recognized
game when you when you finally find
you're equal in battle you gotta you
gotta call it like you see it i think
that's just play
i mean for me yeah he's got a got a real
strong like palpatine
energy like that's always the emperor's
move it's like oh actually i don't want
to fight you
you should join me because you're so
great and like and uh i think you gotta
you know you gotta go even bigger yeah
palpatine's already
already done that on the basic level so
now it's just you gotta really
seduce him when him over uh
all right keep going kiss and so don't
worry if you get
lost because you can get the gist of
demon slayer if you've seen any other
shown in anime
the good guys have the big eyes and neon
clothes the bad guys are all pale pretty
boys and or tentacles
there's some kind of rigid power level
hierarchy was it really an upper ranked
demon
everyone screams the names of their
attacks out loud water surface slash
a third form blazing universe
there's always a secret reserve of power
you can unlock on the brink of defeat
and the predictable death of the
protagonist's mentor that still somehow
works cause damn if goku doesn't go down
like a champ
what a fighter even made his mom proud
it's just so noble
i'm not crying you're crying everyone's
crying
even that bird is crying
[Laughter]
was that intentional do we think yes
right yeah
yeah so so that's one of the the big
things where you're like
oh people are going to be lost because
they use those birds to send messages to
slayers
so like that's how they get gigs right
yeah it's like the bird shows up and
it's like
and thomas yeah all right
all right thanks bird yeah everybody
gets a bird
it's a bird it's my birth my birthday um
and uh yeah so that was one where i was
like oh they did not explain why a bird
shut up bird that bird is a liar
oh safari planet oh yeah and then they
uh so that bird i assume talk to
everyone else from the show that you
know and love and you're like oh wow
it's that guy yep uh yeah um so everyone
won't spread the word
the plot of luke and train yeah that
bird spread the word for sure
uh all right cool keep going so get
ready for one anime-ass anime
and if you have a tolerance for that
sort of thing this is one of the better
ones
because it looks absolutely amazing most
of the humor survives the cultural gap
and there's an extended sequence where
the hero learns to quickly chop his own
head off in his dreams to wake up long
enough to jump the head off a demon
train and get safe from accidentally
chopping his head off for real
by a friend who wears the chopped off
head of the boar who raised him
never change enemy never change yeah i
mean pause
i just want a second that is the the
animation look great and that's just the
kind of thing you don't get
you don't get in uh from hannah barbera
is
the uh uh is the next slitting train
fight uh inception series with the pig
man
you just don't get it and uh and it's
just so refreshing to see something uh
original but
i don't know does that happen in every
anime is that like oh they're doing the
old the old suicide dream montage train
fight again
by slicing off your own head now i mean
you know obviously like most of the
tropes are there except for the slicing
your own head off in a dream
bit but in terms of like the visuals
spencer like yeah i think the show's
just slick as hell looking
um i i finally started tuning in because
uh my wife is
much stronger of a of an anime senpai
than like
like called me into like watch an action
sequence and then i was finally like
okay
can we start the show over so i can
watch it uh yeah it's it's it's pretty
rad
yeah it's great the the combination of i
know well the cg stuff
still don't like it didn't like it don't
like it today
um i love it yeah uh but when they're
doing cg or computer animation to like
mimic painted 2d animation when the uh
when they're swinging those swords
around that's that's very cool i would
definitely get that in a wall scroll
yeah like i said before there is a i
feel like there is a nostalgia element
to this like this feels a bit more like
the anime of like 15
20 years ago to me in some ways
and that's what i like that's the surest
way to my anime heart is like if you
could bring it back to the early aughts
like oh okay now you're speaking my
language yeah this
definitely was an anime where i would
have dated a boy who had that ending
scene on the back of a shirt
remember those bowling shirts with all
of those
ketchum anxiety charlotte's weed
what's in the box
lion-o and
demon the tank engine's big adventure
you want to bet on a naked boar man
fighting a psychic child in his dreams
[Laughter]
that's the crossover that the world
deserves if someone could make
like an anime moog and train money plane
crossover
i will i will have that framed and hung
behind me
uh that was great um super fun thank you
joe for providing all of that
uh much needed context and commentary um
and thank you audience for watching
please subscribe please like hit the
bell so you never miss another thing
will we do anime again who's to say i
think we probably will uh
because they've stopped making other
movies and tv shows so
that's it nothing else it's just
animation from here on out heading
straight to my hero baby
there we go um yeah okay fine i've heard
enough about that one we'll we'll
finally get in
um now uh we have deleted scenes
i imagine if they're ready to roll let's
roll them now
or why his friend looks like the cover
of a romance novel written by pigs
you know i'm sure they explain this in
the show but i kind of hope they don't
just give the guy a warhead
screw it looks fun like zanitsu
an obnoxious coward who can pikachu
quick attack in his sleep
but his main mission is to pork his
friend's sister
starring ready slayer one
scent of a demon are you afraid of this
ark
tweaker two fighter pig fighter pig
does whatever a fighter pig does boar's
head premium sliced meats
foxy crate of the furious my incubus
teacher
smoking hash era sent by burn notice me
red goku
and that's right mr hand
from the train murder on a disorienting
express
he has tuberculosis is contagious you
know
at least we're a mass kid come on demons
are bad enough
yes there you go yeah uh he respects
personal
freedom
[Laughter]
on a demon train we have enough problems
as it is yes
right get it together those are fun
train punishments
um all right moving on no trauma from
the train come on
show trauma from the training come on
folks
working overtime through grade a puns um
your questions and comments uh chris
brown no relation i hope
uh should they do a live action series
slash
movie um no they should never do
live-action anime or
i'm gonna say no until it works and it
has not worked yet
right yeah no no i co-signed that i
don't want to see
any attempt of them i don't want to see
timothee chalamet
carrying a girl in a box i just don't
think it translates there's just
it's lose lose like if you try to do it
and make it look and feel exactly like
the original show well it doesn't work
it just feels like a pale imitation of
something but if you try to reinvent it
then the fans are like what is this this
is the thing i like get out of here so
it's like what do you there's there's no
good answer i don't think
i have a you know the only thing i have
hopes for is
uh jon cho's uh
but that's such like a grounded anime
like
it seems like that feel that feels like
firefly but with a little bit more style
like
it also feels like it's so classic at
this point like it's like such a
granddaddy of the
of the whole thing that like we're
removed enough that we're like all right
let's see what they do it doesn't feel
like
everybody has that personal stake like
they would if it was demon slayer or my
hero academia so they
attack on titan something that's big
right now yeah i do
my hope is oh go ahead spencer
um at some point i think um
dicaprio has been like trying to make
akira
live action which would be hilarious
take away
tv tried to make that yeah yeah like
they've all kind of knocked that around
i do just want to see the third act of
of live action akira
um if nothing else it's funny too
because there are casting calls for here
like every five years
yeah yeah um and then they they don't
seem to go anywhere
it's not gonna happen what i wish is
that the message would be received that
like these make
so much money yeah that someone would
just invest in doing 2d animation
on a on a large scale and that would be
nice instead of the lesson being like
what if we turn this into a real movie
like we should make more 2d make a high
budget version of this
because you can't you can't do it live
you can't yeah um
okay james bond asks what's your take on
the elemental sword effects do you feel
they're literal or metaphorical or
something in between i didn't know that
was even a question i feel like they
were those are real flames
shooting out of that guy's sword uh oh i
yeah i've i've been assuming that these
guys really
shoot things out of their swords yeah
can you explain how like the power the
power system of the
the different breaths work sorry to put
you on the spot joe
go no
[Laughter]
different breathing techniques that make
different
techniques but uh he doesn't use the
fire as a breath it's like a dance that
his dad knew and he like
unlocked it accidentally oh there is
mention of the day
right that's what he's asking about at
the beginning is the dance his dad used
to do right
i think they're i mean i do wish that
there would be like a cutaway scene
after he uses water breathing where like
everything is kind of soaked do you
think that would be hilarious
if i'm like demon slain let's go guys
and they just drop through three inches
of water
what happened was everything changed
when the fire nation attacked i think
that's what it really comes back
you know that they look dope they do
that they're definitely the best looking
part
um okay so uh i should pause to just say
a lot of people apparently
have chimed in daniel y kevin brown noel
meyer to say
actually zenitsu is good um actually
so there you go a lot of people a lot of
people showing love for
uh for the little naruto uh scared boy
um
but maybe he's funny i don't know i
didn't mind him too much in the movie
but i can see how that would be grading
over a
series he's just not in this movie very
much he was i did not know there was
already fan backlash but he he was my
least
it just felt like the other characters
all had like a few layers
and he does not really have have lames
yeah yeah
um all right so uh jared johnson says
uh since we got the movie are we gonna
get an honest tv trailer for demon
slayer probably not i think we do a
different
anime first to be honest i think we'll
probably do my hero academia
obviously attack on titans out there um
and i don't know you guys watch that
godzilla singular point one that's on
netflix i was checking that one
okay okay oh it's kind of fun it's like
a it's like about like engineers who
built
jet jaguar and then all of a sudden like
kaiju starts showing up and it's like oh
yeah have this robot so al-mughdov right
so wait spencer is tanjiro danielle's
netsko
joe is any two and lawn is nosque uh
please don't put me in a box
i just wow you just boxed danielle for
sure
wow don't box women you guys yeah really
don't put your women in
boxes or fridges she's not a demon
is kind of a part of a half of a demon
he's definitely ten zero because he's
the no cause
of course you would because you're
tangier and you're you're the purest boy
yourself
the selfless one yeah
that guy who stabbed me okay oh i hope
he's okay that
oh my god what a giving nurturer he
thinks he's dying
he sees another guy he's like oh he's
going to have to die knowing that he
killed me that poor man like wow you're
really above and beyond yeah what a guy
um okay final question from stephen h uh
if you had to wear an animal's head on
your head what animal would you choose
oh am i marrying it like it's like we're
going full midsomer like it's oh it's
not like a hat like i'm pulling an
animal's head over my head yeah you have
to you're inside the head
style like in those suitcases for
argument's sake let's say you
you can maybe enlarge the animal so it's
head sized like if you wanted to wear a
frog's head like that's what i was
asking
a tiny animal you can pick a small
animal sure but it's a very
large version so that's pretty gross oh
then like a micro pig
but still a micro pig even though
they're not real they eventually turn
into like big pigs but keep them with
the small head
oh come on how cute would i be with a
little pig's head
it wouldn't be micro anymore the the
smallness is the is the thing but like
human heads portions yeah small i'm
gonna go with like a pigeon head because
i feel like a larger
pigeon like those eyes are very
off-putting just that weird just side
eye that
looks like a butt i think is just a very
off-putting eye
um and then you go around uh with the
song no pigeons playing in the
background
the response to no scrubs uh i feel like
you go midsomer i feel like you go full
like black bear like grizzly bear like
get a you know like that
one i think just with the way i already
shuffle around as a middle-aged man it's
already
pretty grizzly bear-like it's not a huge
adjustment
you know i'm already like scratching my
back against large posts
so i think it's a natural fit yeah i'd
go red panda i think it'd be like
you know people would be kind of
disarmed by that um
they wouldn't think to ask why are you
wearing a severed red panda head
yeah yeah so no one would mess with you
like he was willing to do that with to a
red panda
[Laughter]
great question stephen thank you keep
keep those coming um
i think this train is pulling into the
last stop on
on the commentary station so uh last
call
uh anything else to say about demon
slayer before we wrap up
watch it with subs with subs okay subs
not dubs
i mean we did we i watched it with subs
but i feel like if we had played
it just the youtube like people watch on
their phone it's too small to uh to read
something
on australia so normally i like normally
i don't i like dubs for animation but i
don't like this one it actually
it felt like if you were going to watch
anything with the dub version this would
be a good one because
like 90 of the communication is
telepathic
anyway so there's not a lot of like
mouths to match up they're always just
thinking and we're hearing their
thoughts anyway
so i usually don't like a dub version
because
it doesn't sort of seem to fit but this
one it didn't really bother me
yeah uh well it was a good time and i
think we will have
a good time next week when we do the
honest trailer for something
uh very sweet um
there's your clue it's very nice and
wholesome uh but i'm sure we'll find
some something to say about it uh
that's your clue uh it's not much of one
but uh what can i say i haven't even
watched it yet
thanks for watching uh i hope you
enjoyed this week's honest real
competitor we'll be back next week for
the same thing
bye-bye
[Music]
you